also like to thank everyone who worked
in this case to build the evidence
against
a cruel and dangerous man
Awards cannot quantify how much our
family have suffered because of the
horrific actions of one man
neither can we quantify the emotional
psychological
physiological and the financial impact
of the crime committed against
Fatima the Hydra
but you know Salma drame
his actions were authorly heartless and
well
and have caused a multi-generational
trauma that we have that we will never
understand
fatimata was a caring daughter
a wife
sister
mother
and a friend
love and compassion could make a person
immortal she would have lived forever
she had a pure heart and was greatly
loved by these people for because of her
personality and qualities
she was most incredible mother to Fatima
and Naima
two angels who deserve a very beautiful
childhood
and a full life
Nottingham and the rest of the world
have been denied potential future
teachers
civil servants
doctors
who knows what they could have been